[Music]
the central character in ursula k le
guin second novel in the earth c series
the tombs of ottawan
is tenar or arja we'll talk about why
she has two names like that in just a
moment
who we see as a young child
and through the course of the novel we
see
move into young womanhood and the most
important
feature
of her life is that early on
she is recognized as the new upcoming
priestess of the nameless ones in the
tombs of ottawa now why is that the case
well this has to do with the religion of
the kargish people as we're going to see
who believe in reincarnation and she is
believed to be the reincarnated
priestess who
uh had died at the same time
as she's born and there's there's a bit
more to it as we'll go into but the idea
is that there's a long line
of priestesses tracing all the way back
the same
being essentially the same soul
has existed in numerous bodies and this
one is just the latest the book actually
begins
with
uh a prologue come and it begins with
these words come home tenner come home
and she's a young child her mother
is is calling her home the father says
why do you let your heart hang on the
child they're coming to take her away
next month for good might as well bury
her and be done with it what's the good
to clinging to one you're bound to lose
she's no good to us if they'd pay for
her when they took her which would be
something but they won't they'll take
her and that's an end of it and
he says a little bit later she isn't
ours she never was since they came here
and said she must be a priestess of the
tombs why can't you
see that and that is exactly what they
do
the first chapter begins the eaton won
by
this ritual that is taking place it's
described in in great detail
by le guin
the child climbs up four of the seven
steps of marble
uh a figure and belted gown of white
wolves stepped suddenly out of the
shadows and strode down the steps to the
child his face was masked with white he
held a sort of polished steel five feet
long without word or hesitation he swung
the sword
up over the girl's neck
as the blade swung to its highest point
and poised a figure in black doubted art
darted out from the left side of the
throne leapt down the stairs stayed the
sacrificers arms with slender arms the
sharp edge of the sword glittered in
mid-air so they balanced for a moment
and then there's a chant oh let the
nameless ones behold the girl given to
them who is verily the one born ever
nameless
let them accept her life in the years of
her life until her death which is also
theirs let them find her acceptable let
her be eaten other voices shrill and
harsh as trumpets replied she is eaten
she has eaten now this is a really
central idea
she's not the only person who is eaten
by the nameless ones we find that
prisoners are also as they die
under the tombs of ottawa eaten by the
nameless ones as well but this is a
person whose identity
consists
in having her identity gone
reduced eaten taken away why so that she
can be the vessel
not just for these old powers of the
earth the nameless ones but also for the
priestess
who has been there this entire time
through a multiplicity of bodies the
previous arja she's called later on and
so there's this entire
ritual i'll just read a little bit more
of this the little girl was taken from
room to room from temple to temple in
one place salt was placed on her tongue
and another she she knelt facing west
while her hair was cut short and washed
with oil and scented vinegar in another
she lay face down on a slab of black
marble behind an altar while shrill
voices saying a lament for the dead
neither she nor any of the priestesses
ate food or
drank water that day as the evening star
said the little girl was put to bed
naked in between sheepskin rugs and a
room she'd never slept in before it was
in a house that had been locked for
years unlocked only that day the room
was higher than it was long and had no
windows there was a dead smell in it
still in stale the silent women left her
there in the dark and the person who
does come to her is this
you know the manon who is going to be
taking care of her until he he dies in
the in the story
and uh he calls her by her name tenar
but now it's time for that name to be
lost it's been
eaten it goes away and for
much of the novel
she is now are the
eaten one and
she learns from one of the other
priestesses uh thar the priestess of the
brother gods the twin gods the
why the explanation for
her being chosen
she's she's actually memorized this as
leguin tells us
um
she tells uh manon tell me how i was
chosen you know thar had told her till
she knew the words by heart at the death
of the one priestess of the tombs of
ottawa
ceremonies of
burial and purification are completed
within one month by the moon's calendar
after this certain of the priestesses
and wardens of the place of the tombs go
forth asking and seeking they seek a
girl child who is born on the night of
the priestess's death when they find a
child they wait and watch it must be
sound of body and mind it must not
suffer from rickets nor the smallpox or
any deformity if it reaches the age of
five years unblemished then it is known
that the body of the child is indeed the
new body
of the priestess who died and the child
is made known to the god-king and aguath
and brought here to her temple and
instructed for a year
then she is taken to the hall of the
throne and her name is given back to
those are who are her masters the
nameless ones she is the nameless one
the priestess ever reborn
and it says this was is all word for
word as far had told her and she never
did to ask for a word more so what we've
got here is an explanation of this is
how the priestess
is reincarnated this is why we brought
you in and then she wants to know a
deeper
and broader how
from manon and he can tell her
tell me how i was chosen and he would
tell her again
and he tells a whole story there that
gives a lot more detail about the
poverty of the family
and looking at the baby
thinking they'd found the reborn one at
last the mother could tell this too she
held the baby and never said a word the
mother actually engages in a
trick she stains the baby's skin with
berry juice and says that she has a
fever which would disqualify her
apparently from being able to be the new
body of the priestess and they washed
that off
she never finds out what happens with
her her mother she asks what did the
mother do when they came to take the
child away manan didn't know he had not
gone with the priestesses on that
journey so we have a narrative of
here's how you got here
and she lives a life that is genuinely
set apart as we find out in that same
chapter
she lives with the other girls for a
year and then she moves to her own
little house as opposed to the great
house which is just for
the priestess where she would live her
entire life and then die and then be
reborn again
brought there
again so there's this cyclical
thing that's taking place we also find
out that she cannot be
punished by the
other priestesses as unfortunately her
friend pentha is who are gets in trouble
gets her in trouble right uh and and
penta bears the the brunt of the
punishment
for our
not in place of her but
she's the one who who gets whipped
scourged right
now there's more to this life set apart
a really important part of this is
getting to learn the
things that are underneath the tombs the
under tombs the great chamber
the
labyrinth and its particular places and
this is something that she has to be
taught
by the other priestesses who have
learned from the previous
arha right so in in chapter three
castle says i have been permitted to
look after certain matters pertaining to
the domain of the nameless ones until
now
if you so desire it is now time for you
to learn and see and take charge of
these matters which you have not yet
remembered in this life
so
what do they do they
they go under the ground and castle
starts showing her
these places
i'm going to read a little bit more of
this so she says at last i shall see my
own domain at last she was 15. it was
over a year since she'd made her
crossing into womanhood and at the same
time had come into her full powers as
the one priestess of the tombs of ottawa
highest of all high priestesses of cargo
lands one whom not even the god king
himself might command they all bowed the
knee to her now even grim thar and
castle all spoke to her with elaborate
deference
but nothing had really changed
nothing happened once the ceremonies of
her consecration were open or over the
days went on as they'd always gone there
was wool to be spun black cloth to be
woven meal to be ground rights to be
performed the nine chants must be sung
nightly the doorways blessed the stones
fed with goats blood twice a year the
dances of the dark of the moon danced
before the empty throne
and the whole year had passed just as
the years before it had passed and were
all the years of her life to pass
so
so
getting to explore the
underground is going to restore some
interest to her life and this is
something that she gets to do
she also is involved in determining the
deaths of the prisoners who have been
sent to her who die
underneath
in the realm of the nameless ones who
are eaten by the nameless ones
as a result and so she
deals with the three prisoners that now
castle is bringing as a problem before
her she also gets to decide what to do
with ged when he is caught within
the
underground
and becomes as she's going to make him
for a brief period a slave of the tombs
so that's an important function she has
her own rituals that she
is herself carrying on right
and
we get a brief description of them
with uh
here we go
um
engaging in some some
things that that tie in with the old
function of the priestess breathing in
fumes and then dancing before the throne
here we go uh the the demands of the
endless ritual of the place brought arha
out of her privacy a couple days later
twin kids had been born out of season to
a she-goat and were to be sacrificed to
the twin god brothers as the custom was
an important rite at which the first
priestess must be present then it was
dark of the moon and the ceremonies of
the darkness must be performed before
the empty throne arja breathed in the
drugging fumes of herbs burning in broad
trays of bronze before the throne and
danced solitary in black she danced for
the unseen spirits of the dead and the
unborn as and as she danced the spirits
crowded the air around her
following the turn and spin of her feet
in the slow sure gestures of her arms
she sang the songs whose words no man
understood which she had learned
syllable by syllable long ago from thar
a choir of priestesses hidden in the
dust behind the great double row of
columns echoed the strange words after
her and the air in the vast ruinous room
hummed with voices as if the crowding
spirits repeated the chants again
and again so there are rituals that she
is carrying on and
they're different from the rituals of
the others which she talks about and
kind of well at least leguin
places in her mind in kind of a
denigrating way here's the the passage
never had the rights and duties of the
day seemed so many or so petty
or so long
the little girls with their pale faces
and furtive ways the restless novices
the priestesses whose looks were stern
and cool but whose lives were all a
secret tangle of jealousies and miseries
and small ambitions and wasted passions
all these women among whom she'd always
lived in who made up the human world to
her
now appeared to her as both pitiable and
boring so that that's the status of
everybody else perhaps with the
exception of the two other high
priestesses right so the lives of others
are filled with ritual but
they're also kind of tawdry
leguin goes on
but she who served great powers she the
priestess of grim night was free of that
pettiness
she did not have to care about the
grinding meanness of their common life
the days whose one delight was likely to
be getting a bigger slop of lamb fat
over your lentils than your neighbor got
she was free of the days all together
underground there were no days there was
always and only
night
now this is when she's already
involved with ged as her prisoner
we also learn in in the story about the
origins of the priestess of the nameless
ones and this ties in with an older time
in the kargish isles this is manon
telling the story in chapter three
long ago he said you know little one
before our four lands joined together
into an empire
before there was a god king over us all
there were a lot of lesser kings princes
chiefs they were always quarreling with
each other and they'd come here to
settle their quarrels
that was how it was they'd come from our
land otawan and from karago at and at
nini and even from her and her all the
chiefs and princes with their servants
and their armies and they'd ask you
what to do they'd ask you
how to do things and you'd go before the
empty throne and give them the counsel
of the nameless ones
so
at one time the priestess had an
oracular or divinatory
function for
all of the nobility of the kargish lands
that has changed in recent times as the
god kings have arrogated to themselves
greater and greater power
but this uh
ancient time is one in which there is a
priestess who's serving the nameless
ones and it's believed to be the same
priestess coming to
birth over and over and over again
providing a kind of continuity and
connection to the older kargish
past
there's a very interesting set of
passages where we find
that
there's a weirdness
to
uh
here we go this is
quite excellent
so
she's learning about the tombs and the
labyrinth she says when was the
labyrinth made in asar and the stern
thin priestess answered mistress i do
not know no one knows
why was it made for the hiding away the
treasures of the tombs and the
punishment of those who tried to steal
those treasures and she asks him about
what's in the labyrinth and they say
a far greater and more ancient treasure
would you look on it yes none but you
the special priestess may enter the
treasury of the tombs you may take your
servants into the labyrinth but not into
the treasury
if even manon entered in there the anger
of the dark would awake would waken he
would not leave the labyrinth alive
there you must go forever i know where
the great treasure is
you
told me the way 15 years ago before you
died
so that i would remember and tell you
when i returned
i can tell you the way to follow in the
labyrinth beyond the painted room and
the key to the treasury is that silver
one on your ring with the figure of a
dragon on the half but you
must go alone so what we have going on
here
is the entire
under tomb
the labyrinth these treasures all of
these things
they are the province of this priestess
and
the other two priestesses
thar and castle the other high
priestesses have helped out they took in
information from the
previous arha and now they're teaching
or reteaching arha what
she already knew and did and said
in the previous flesh
you can't even say the previous life
because she's still living out the same
life
and
there's there's a kind of interesting
thing here um
she says after all had she not seen
these treasures before she can wait for
it right and she and she leguin says it
still made her feel strange when thar
and kossel spoke to her of things she'd
seen or said before she died she knew
indeed she had died and been reborn in a
new body at the hour of her old body's
death not only once 15 years ago but 50
years ago and before that and before
that back down the years and hundreds of
years generation before generation to
the very beginning of years when the
labyrinth was dug
and the stones were raised and the first
priestess of the nameless ones lived in
this place and danced before the empty
throne they were all one all those lives
and hers she was the first priestess
all human beings were forever reborn but
only she
arha was reborn forever as herself a
hundred times she had learned the ways
and turnings of the labyrinth and come
to the hidden room at last
now here's a great thing to end on
yet it was always strange when thar said
you told me before you died
so
on the one hand araha is able to accept
this
this story about her own meaning her own
origins her very identity on the other
hand she feels it
still as
weird as strange
and she's living this life where she is
definitely
set apart as something as someone
very special
but it's also a
life
of
you might say deep loneliness and
for at least some parts boredom as well
and not fully knowing
her own identity as we're going to see
later on in the novel as it proceeds
you